[موسيقى]
مساء الخير انا ميسون الواهد واقدم لكم
اخبار الساعه كالعاده نبدا بابرز العناوين
مرهق
[تصفيق]
لرئاسيات 2024 لكنه يؤجل الاعلان الرسمي
حتى استعداد حملته
السفير السعودي في اليمن يؤكد ان زيارته
الى صنعاء هدفها تثبيت الهدنه والوصول الى
حل سياسي دائم
وفي جديد الوثائق المسربه خلل في تشغيل
انظمه القنابل الذكيه الامريكيه يجعلها
صيدا سهلا لدفاعات روسيا
والصين تقود بريكس للتوسع في الشرق الاوسط
ووضع حد لهيمنه الدولار عبر التبادل
التجاري بالعملات المحليه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن بدا
بتعبيد الطريق امامه نحو البيت الابيض
طامحا بولايه ثانيه اذا اعلن نيته بالترشح
للانتخابات الرئاسه لعام 204
رابطا موعد الاعلان الرسمي لحملته بمدى
استعداده وسائل اعلام امريكيات تحدثت في
وقت سابق عن غموض حول الوقت الذي سيعلن
فيه بايدن بدء حملته الانتخابيه بشكل رسمي
في وقت اظهرت استطلاعات رايا امريكيه عدم
رغبه الديمقراطيين في ترشح جو بايدن
لولايه ثانيه
من واشنطن ينضم الي مراسل العربيه حسين
التوضي حسين اهلا بك معنا لماذا يتانى
الرئيس بايدن باعلان ترشحه لانتخابات
الرئاسه لعشرين 24
تحيه لك ميسون الرئيس بايدن خلال الفتره
الماضيه كرر نيته بانه يريد ان يترشح كلام
من المتوقع ان هذا الترشح في فبراير
الماضي اثناء خطاب حاله الاتحاد لكن ذلك
لم يحدث ثم توقع البعض عن ترشحه في الربيع
ولكن اخر التقارير تتحدث الان عن انه اجل
الموضوع حتى نهايه الصيف لماذا الرئيس بدر
اولا ليس مستعجلا ميسون ثانيا الاعلان
المتاخر عن الترشح للرئاسه يعطيه مزيدا من
الوقت ليركز على
وظيفته كرئيس الولايات المتحده وللترويج
لاعماله كما ان هناك العديد من العوامل
التي تلعب دورا في اتخاذ هذا القرار
ان لا يكون هناك مرشح ديمقراطي في مواجهته
وهذا امر مستبعد حتى الان اضافه الى اننا
يجب ان نذكر هنا بان الرئيس بايدن والبيت
الابيض يتحضر لمعركه مع الجمهوريين في
مجلس النواب في شان التمويل
الانفاق الحكومي ورفع سقف الدين هناك تحدي
كبير في هذا الموضوع كما ان الرئيس بايدن
يريد ان يترشح من خلال اعلان عن انجاز
كبير يحققه في رئاسته صحيح انه حتى الان
اقتصاديا هناك حديث عن انجازات اقتصاديه
خاصه فيما يتعلق
بمجال التوظيف والوظائف ولكن يجب ان لا
ننسى بان التضخم مرتفع وحتى الان سياسه
كبح هذا التضخم لم تنتهي وهناك توقعات
برفع المزيد من سعر الفائده حسين الى اي
مدى نسبه قبول حزب الديمقراطي
بالرئيس بايدن وان لا يكون هناك من ينافسه
خاصه اذا الحزب الجمهوري تبنى ترشيح
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للمرشحين وجود مرشحين ديمقراطيين
ليس من المتوقع ان يرشح الحزب الديمقراطي
احد في الرئيس بدر العاده على هذا المنوال
عندما يكون الرئيس في منصبه الحزب الذي
ينتبه اليه لا يرشح احد مقابيله اذا كان
لديه طبعا الحقيه في ولايه الثانيه طبعا
هناك حديث عن حاكم كاليفورنيا
الذي
يقال بانه لديه طموحات سياسيه لكنه حتى
لانه ايضا ينفي نيته بان يترشح لمنصب
الرئاسه الامريكيه بالنسبه لقبول
الديمقراطيين هناك الكثير من التحليلات من
يرى بانه ليس كل الديمقراطيين يريدون
الرئيس بايدن ان يترشح للرئاسه وما بين من
يقول بانه اذا بالفعل قدم ملف ترشحي
يساندونه بغض النظر عن اي شيء وخاصه اذا
كان المقابل له من الحزب الجمهوري هو
دونالد ترامب هناك توقعات وهناك مق الان
هنا في الولايات المتحده تتحدث عن ان
الرئيس
المرشح الجمهوري الوحيد الذي يستطيع ان
يهزمه هو دونالد ترامب فاذا ترشحت ترامب
من المحتمل ان يلقى تاييدا اكبر من
الديمقراطيين
نتحدث طبعا هنا عن بايدن سيلقى بيضا اكبر
من ديمقراطيين لمواجهات ترامب كما فعل في
المره الاولى عام 2016
العربيه حسين
يحاول الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب من عن ابيه السابق معك بنس من
المتولي امام هيئه المحلفين الفيدراليه
بشهادته في احداث السادس من يناير فريق
ترامب القانوني قام بتقديم استئناف
للمحكمه لمنع عدد من مساعدي ترامب
السابقين من تقديم شهاداتهم امام المحكمه
[موسيقى]
اكد السفير السعودي في اليابان محمد
الجابر ان زيارته لصنعاء برفقته وفد عماني
هدفها تثبيت الهدنه ووقف اطلاق النار
موضحا ان العمل جار في صنعاء لدعم تبادل
الاسره وبحث سبل الحوار والعمل على حل
سياسي دائم ومستدام في اليمن واضاف السفير
محمد الجابر ان المملكه وقفت حكومه وشعبا
مع اليمن منذ عقود في احلك الازمات وان
الجهود مستمره منذ عام 20 احد عشر لتحقيق
تطلعات الشعب اليمني والعمل على عوده
الامن والاستقرار والازدهار الاقتصادي
لليمن
وزالت الخارجيه الامريكيه من جهتها رحبت
بجهود انهاء الحرب في اليمن وزياره السفير
السعودي لصنعاء ولطالما كانت السعوديه
مصدرا لمبادرات الحل في اليمن لصالح
استقرار المنطقات ورفع المعاناه الانسانيه
عن الشعب اليمني متابع
قبل حوالي 12 عاما ومنذ اليوم الاول
للازمه في اليمن كانت السعوديه مصدرا
لمبادره الحل سعت في غير ما مره للحفاظ
على هذا البلد موحدا ومستقرا
شكلت الرياض مركزا لاطلاق عديد المبادرات
لجمع شمل اليمنيين لصالح استقرار المنطقه
ورفع المعاناه الانسانيه عن الشعب اليماني
واشنطن سبق واكدت عبر وزير خارجيتها ان
السعوديه اظهرت رغبتها في الوصول الى
اتفاق سلام باليمن
السعوديه اظهرت من خلال افعالها رغبتها في
الوصول الى اتفاق سلام في اليمن وهو امر
ايجابي للغايه
من واشنطن الى باريس استمرت الاشادات
الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون من جهته
رحب العام الماضي بجهود السعوديه ودعمها
للهدنه
نشيد بالجهود السعوديه للتوصل الى حل
سياسي شامل في اليمن
من جهتها دعمت دوله الامارات جهود
السعوديه لتحقيق حل سياسي للحرب في اليمن
لاحلال السلام ووضع حد دائم للاعمال
العدائيه بين جميع الاطراف اليمنيه
المختلفه فالرياض وحدت المكونات اليمنيه
في المجلس الرئاسي واستطاعت انهاء
الخلافات التي عطلت عمل المجلس خلال
الاشهر الماضيه التواصل او الاتصال بين
الاشقاء السعوديه والحوثيين المملكه لم
تغلق بابها مطلقا طوال سنوات الحرب كانت
دائما المملكه يعني اي باب ينفتح في هذا
المجال سواء بشقه السياسي او بشقه الامنيه
كان دائما يظل الباب مفتوح وكان الرساله
الرئيسيه نحن
باي فرصه ستتيح لنا
ان نجمع اليمنيين ان نقدم اي محفزات
الجانب الحوثي حتى ياتي الى الطاوله سنقوم
بهذا الامر هي اذا شعله امل جديده او
قدتها الرياض بعد محاولات عديده لانهاء
حاله الاستقرار في هذا البلد العربي سيرا
في طريق السلام بلال البشتين العربي
ينضم الى من الرياض مانع المطر يعض مؤتمر
الحوار اليمني سابقا استزمانه اهلا بكم
معنا الى اي مدى هذه التطورات هذه الزياره
اليوم للسفير السعوديه الى صنعاء مؤشر
اولي على انهاء الازمه اليمنيه
نعم تحيه لكل المشاهدين الكرام الحقيقه ان
الزياره هي تعكس الاراده السياسيه التي
تتمتع بها السعوديه والجديه نحن المضي
قدما في خيار السلام رغم العقبات الكبيره
التي
وضعت امام هذا المسار خلال فتره الثمان
سنوات من الحرب
وبسبب التاثير الايراني في ما مضى على
الحوثيين ودعمهم المستمر الحوثيه التي ادت
الى اطاله ابد الحرب برغم ان المملكه قدمت
مبادرات عديده في اتجاه
الدخول في مسار سلمي يحقق سلام مستدام في
اليمن بدءا من المبادره الخليجيه ثم اثناء
الحوار الوطني ودعمها الحوار الوطني في
اليمن ثم بعد ذلك حتى عندما تم توقيع
الاتفاق السلم والشراكه وبعد ذلك ايضا في
الدعوه لانعقاد مؤتمر رياض لانقاذ اليمن
والذي كان من المفترض ان يحضروا فيه
الحوثيين في 2015 الا انه امتنعوا عن ذلك
واختاروا خلال الحرب ثم جولات المشاورات
المتعدده التي
خاضتها الحكومه اليمنيه
وبدعم كبير من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اي اتفاق قريب مثلا وهل سيكون هذا الاتفاق
على حل جذري ام هذا الحل سيكون على مراحل
انا اعتقد ان المعطيات حاليا
تشير الى ان هناك جاهزيه نسبيه للسلام او
ان الظروف السلام توفرت الى حد ما اولا هو
وجود داعم اقليمي كبير للعمليه السلميه
المتمثله في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ووجود مواقف دوليه مؤيده لهذا الجهد الذي
تقوم بها السعوديه اضافه الى ان
اذا صدقت نوى ايران واوقفت دعمها للمحوثيه
لا تستطيع ان تستمر في الحرب اضافه الى
الجهد الذي بذل في جانب الشرعيه من خلال
توحيد المكونات اليمنيه في اطار مجلس
القياده الرئاسي وايضا الحاله الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه التي وصل اليها الشعب من حاله
الضيق من من من استمرار الحرب عدم قدره
المجتمع على تحمل تبعات جديده لهذه الحرب
وبالتاكيد ان مسار السلام لن يكون سهلا
وينبغي ايضا ان يمر على مراحل وان هذه
المراحل يجب ان تكون ضمن مسار استراتيجي
واضح يفضي في النهايه الى سلام مستدام
بالتاكيد المعضله الامنيه هي معضله كبيره
وكان اليمنيون قد وصلوا الى اتفاق عليها
في مشاورات الكويت في
مشاورات الكويت التي استمرت فتره طويله
تقريبا 110 ايام الا ان الميليشيات وقتها
امتنعت عن التوقيع بعد ان توافق الناس على
كل شيء في هذا المسار الامني الذي يحتاج
اليوم الى اعاده تفعيله بما يسهم في تخفيف
الحال الانسانيه وتهيئه الاجواء نحو حوار
سياسي على مستقبل اليمن شكرا لك من الرياض
مانع المطري الحوار اليمني سابقا
في اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعد لحظات الو
ماسك يسعى لمنافسه صناعه الاخبار وتحويل
تويتر الى المنصه الرئيسيه تلغي دور
الاعلام التقليدي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اعلنت القياده الاستراتيجيه
الامريكيه ان القوات الامريكيه ستبدا
تدريبات سنويه على القياده والسيطره
للقوات النوويه غدا الثلاثاء بمشاركه عدد
من الدول مضيحه ان مثل هذه التدريبات تقام
سنويا وليست ردا على تصرفات اي دوله
والهدف منها تقييم جاهزيه القوات النوويه
وقدرات الرد الاستراتيجيه
طرق البحريه الامريكيه تتشعب واليوم تسلك
طريقها في بحر جنوب الصين بالقرب من جزر
سبرايتلي فالمدمره ميليوس التي تحمل
صواريخ مسيره دخلت بحر الصين الجنوبي توغل
وصف بالاستفزازي وغير القانوني من قبل
بكين التي تواصل مناوراتها حول تايوان
لليوم الثالث والاخير فيما البحريه
الامريكيه تمسكت بقانونيه العمليه التي
قامت بها المدمره يو اس اس ميليس على
اعتبار انها تتوافق مع القانون الدولي
وتدعم الحقوق والحريات والاستخدامات
المشروعه للبحر
المدمره تشق طريقها في مياه بحر الصين
الجنوبي واصطحاله ترقب صينيه بسبب توغل
السفينه الامريكيه في مياه الصين
الاقليميه فما هي قدرات هذه السفينه
الحربيه
المدمره قادره على القيام بمهام متعدده
لاداء حرب مضاده للطائرات والسفن
والغواصات كل ذلك في وقت واحد كما انها
قادره على اكتشاف الصواريخ الباليستيه
وتتبعها والاشتباك معها
وذلك عن طريق رادار الصفيف المرحلي متعدد
الوظائف
تحمل هذه السفن صواريخ مسيره وصواريخ
هاربون المضاده للسفن
وفي ملف بحر الصين الجنوبيه اكد المتحدث
باسم وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه ان القوات
التايوانيه في حاله تاهب قصوى للحفاظ على
الامن القومي بطريقه عقلانيه واصفا منورات
العسكريه الصينيه بانها تزعزع الاستقرار
وتعرض لان الاقليمي للخطر
ستحافظ قواتنا على سيادتنا وامننا القومي
بطريقه رصينه وعقلانيه ومدروسه في غضون
ذلك ظلت وحده دفاعنا الجوي في حاله تاهب
قصوى انهم يراقبون عن كثب كل هدف محتمل
ويستجيبون لحاله الطوارئ
تصنف كواحده من اربع غواصات مزوده بصواريخ
موجهه في اسطول البحريه الامريكيه وقد
اكملت اكثر من 50 دوريه قبل تحويلها الى
غواصه صاروخيه موجهه لدى غواصه فلوريدا
طاقمان الازرق والذهبي وتشمل حوالي 160
بحارا يتناوبون على تشغيلها وينتشرون عاده
مع السفينه لمده ثلاثه اشهر قبل التبديل
[موسيقى]
والان الى الوثائق المسربه حيث قالت وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه ان هذه الوثائق
الاستخباراتيه التي تم تسريبها على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي هي شبيهه بتلك التي يتم
تقديمها لكبار القاده واضافت الوزاره ان
بعض الصور في هذه الوثائق يبدو انه تم
تعديلها وانه تم اطلاع الوزير استون على
التسريب يوم السادس من ابريل الدفاع
الامريكيه قالت ايضا انها اتخذت اجراءات
لمعرفه كيف تم توزيع هذه الوثائق ومن
الاشخاص الذين كانت لديهم القدره للوصول
اليها واضافها مسؤول امريكي انه يتم
التواصل مع العديد من القاده حول العالم
للتاكيد على سلامه العمل الاستخباراتي
الامريكي واشار الى ان الوثائق المسربه هي
مصنفه على انها عاليه السريه ومن الممكن
ان تتسبب في خساره ارواح المصادر
وزنه الدفاع ستحول القضيه الى وزاره العدل
للتحقيق الجنائي لكن لا اعتقد انهم وصلوا
الى اي نتيجه حول كيفيه تسريب الوثائق ولا
حجم الضرر على الامن القومي
اذا تحقيقاتهم بالجمله باتت على طاوله
الاداره الامريكيه منها تخص معدات عسكريه
واخرى وثائق سريه واشخاصا اذ افادت وسائل
اعلام امريكيه بان واشنطن فتحت تحقيقا
بالخلل الحاصل خلال تشغيل انظمه القنابل
الذكيه جيدا في اوكرانيا وثائق سريه يوزعم
انها تخص البانتاجون كشفت ان هناك شكوك بل
انه هناك شكوك بشان استخدام روسيا نظام
تشويش يعيق عمل النظام الصواريخ الامريكيه
ويمكن تزويد جيدا
بقنابل غير موجهه تزن ما بين
2900 كيلو جرام وبمجرد اطلاقها تفتح
القنبله جناحيها ما يسمح لها بالتحليق
لمسافه تصل الى 72 كيلومترا وتضاف من مدى
بل تضاعف المدى السلاح الاصلي ثلاث مرات
[موسيقى]
موقع دولار الامريكي كعمله رئيسيه في
العالم والتجاره الدوليه قد يهتز ما هو
السبب ان التحالف بريكس الذي يضم خمس دول
من بينهم الصين والهند يحاول تغيير ذلك
وبدات هذه المحاولات في الظهور داخل الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا تحاول الصين بناء
نفوذ دبلوماسي لمواجهه هيمنه الدول
المتقدمه في الامم المتحده والمنظمات
العالميه وتقود دول بريكس للتوسع في الشرق
الاوسط وتعزيز التبادل التجاري غير
المعتمد على الدولار الامريكي هدف الدول
الخمس القضاء على هيمنه الدولار في
التبادلات التجاريه الدوليه وهو ما قد
يفيد على وجه خاص دول الشرق الاوسط التي
لديها تبادل تجاري ضخم مع روسيا والصين
وفق تقرير لشبكه سي ان ان
[موسيقى]
الى الشان التركي حيث اكد وزير الخارجيه
مولود شاوش اوغلو ان نظيره المصري سامح
شكري سيزول انقر هذا الاسبوع واضاف اهله
ان انقره والقاهره تقتربان من مرحله تعيين
السفراء
اكد وزير الخارجيه التركيه مولود شاوش
ايضا موعد عقد الاجتماع الرباعي مع وزراء
خارجيه سوريا وايران وروسيا في مطلع مايو
المقبل وكانت احدى الصحف السوريه نقلت عن
السفير الروسي لدى دمشق الكسندر
قوله ان الاجتماع الرباعي على مستوى وزراء
خارجيه سوريا وتركيا وايران وروسيا تاجل
الى مطلع الشهر المقبل بعدما كان من
المتوقع عقده اليوم الاثنين
[موسيقى]
طموحات الملك دير الامريكيه ومالك منصه
تويتر العم ماسك لا تنتهي وعواصف افكاره
كل يوم باتجاه ماسك يسعى لمنافسه صناعه
الاخبار فلطالما كانت لديه نظره قادمه
تجاه الاعلام معتبرا انه مدفوع ومملوك
للمعلنين وبشرائه شركه تويتر يصورهم الان
على انهم منافسون يحاولون حمايه احتكار
القله للمعلومات في الوقت الذي يسعى فيه
لوضع منصته كمصدر اخباري بعض المنافذ
الاخباريه عارضت حديث ماسك بان صحافتها
تتاثر بالمعلنين قائله ان لديها انقسامات
منذ فتره طويله بين الاعمال التجاريه
والجوانب التحريريه لعملياتها وان العديد
منها لديها عائدات اشتراك قويه ماسك ومنذ
توليه منصب مدير تويتر في اواخر اكتوبر
الماضي توعد بمقاومه الاعلام التقليدي وان
يجعل منصته المصدر الاساسي للخبر
ايضا في اروقه اعرق واقدم وسيله اعلان
بريطانيه هناك محاولات حديثه لتهدئه
الزوبعه التي احدثها ايضا مالك موقع تويتر
فبعد تصنيفه لهيئه الاذاعه البريطانيه
مموله حكوميا سارت الاخيره للبحث عن حل
سريع مع الشركه علما بان الاذاعه الوطنيه
البريطانيه تمول في الغالب من قبل الاسر
في المملكه المتحده من خلال رسوم الترخيص
الملياردير الامريكي ايضا تراجع عن نفس
القرار بشان حساب شبكه ان في ار بل ان ار
بي الامريكيه بعد ايام من وسمها بوسيله
اعلام تابعه للدوله هذا ولم يقدم تويتر
تعريفا حتى اللحظه لما يعتبره وسائل اعلام
مموله من الحكومه
سنتابع في اخبار الساعه بعد قليل
نتنياهو يحسم الجدل كلانت سيبقى وزيرا
للدفاع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى اخبار الساعه مجددا في
المدينه المنوره وبعد تشغيل المسجد النبوي
بكامل الطاقه الاستعابيه بموسم رمضان شهد
القطاع السياحي والفندقي نسب اشغال مرتفعه
تصل الى 90% ما جعل مشغل القطاع الفندقي
يعملون على رفع التجهيزات ومستويات
التشغيل للتعامل مع الاعداد المليونيه
التي تشهدها المدينه المنوره
بعد سماح الجهات المختصه في السعوديه
باداء مناسك العمره والصلاه في المسجد
النبوي بكامل الطاقه الاستيعابيه دون قيود
يشهد قطاع الفنادق في المدينه المنوره
اقبالا ملحوظا ونسب اشغال مرتفعه وصلت الى
90% مع دخول شهر رمضان سنه هذه لقينا في
اقبال اكثر من العام الماضي تقريبا في
زياده تقريبا من 10 الى 15% في اعداد
المعتمرين وفي الزوار كذلك يعني لقينا في
اقبال في عدد المصلين حسب الاحصائيات اللي
بترد من رئاسه شو الحرمين تتفاوت اسعار
الغرف الفندقيه مع قرب دخول العشر الاواخر
من شهر رمضان وبحسب قربها من المسجد
النبوي اتصلوا الى 3000 ريال لليله
الواحده نظرا لزياده الطلب عدد الغرف
الفندقيه الموجوده في المدينه تقريبا 355
فندق تشكل تقريبا 65 الى 66 الف غرفه
فندقيه كانت نسبه الاشغال في هذا العام
تتجاوز التسعين الى 95% في بعض الايام
ولكن بمتوسط طول الشهر كانت 85% بالنسبه
للاسعار صار عليها زيادات تقريبا ابن 20
الى 30% خطوات ايجابيه اتخذتها الجهات
المهنيه بخدمه الضيوف الرحمن اسهمت في
زياده الاقبال على القدوم لتاديه المناسك
والعمره والشعائر في مقدمتها تاشيره
الزياره والسياحه المفتوحه طوال العام من
المدينه المنوره سلطان السلمي العربيه
اعتبارا من اليوم تبدا رئاسه شؤون الحرمين
تفعيل خطتها التنفيذيه للعشر الاواخر في
الشهر رمضان لاستقبال المعتمرين والزوار
والمصلين تاتي هذه الخطوه بعد نجاح
الخطتين التشغيليه الاولى والثانيه
والاستعداد بكافه القوى العامله والخدمات
الموجوده عبر عدد من الوكالات والجهات
المسانده كما تم استكمال تهيئه اعمال
التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه لاستقبال ملايين
المصلين والمعتمرين في العشر الاواخر من
رمضان
مكه المكرمه ينضم الي مراسله العربيه
اسامه القاسم اسامه اهلا بك معنا الاعداد
الى اين وصلت اليوم كيفيه العمل في هذه
الخطه التشغيليه الثالثه في العشر الاواخر
من شهر رمضان المبارك
اهلا ميسون تحيه طيبه لك ولجميع المشاهدين
العربيه انقل لكم الصوت والصوره اليوم من
هنا من ساحات المسجد الحرام نعم وصلت
اعداد الزوار المعتمين اليوم الى حوالي 18
مليون زائر ومعتمر منذ بدايه شهر رمضان
المبارك ثم من بدا الخطه التشغيليه
الثالثه التي اعلنت عنها رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين للبدء بها في العشر الاواخر وهي
الخطه التشغيليه الاكبر في شهر رمضان
المبارك نتحدث اليوم عن عدد من الخدمات
التي تقدمها رئاسه شؤون الحرمين حتى اتحدث
لكم عن هذه الخدمات انقل لكم هذه الصوره
من ساحات المسجد الحرام والتي تشهد
وازدحاما شديدا عند باب الملك عبد العزيز
وباب الملك فهد اشهر الابواب المؤديه الى
صحن المطاط هنا في الحرم المكي الشريفه عن
تراسه شون الحرمين عن اكثر من 4000 عامل
وعامله لنظافه وتنظيف المسجد الحرام سواء
على المستوى الارضيات او حتى على مستوى
سجاديد المسجد الحرام هناك ايضا اكثر من
الف عامل لسقيا زمزم تم تقديم اكثر من 25
مليون لتر من سقيا زمزم منذ بدايه شهر
رمضان المبارك وتوقعات ايضا بين تزيد هذه
الاعداد خلال الايام القادمه ميسون نحن
نتحدث اليوم ايضا عن وصول الزوار
المعتمرين يتحدث عن حركتهم الكبيره جدا في
ساحات المسجد الحرام ودخولهم ايضا الى
اسواق مكه المكرمه والاسواق التي تاتي
بجانب المسجد الحرام نشهد الان ايضا
الحركه التسوقيه للزوار والمعتمرين
ودخولهم لشراء بعض الاغراض وايضا المطاعم
والمقاهي المتواجده بجانبات ساحات المسجد
الحرام كل هذه الحركه جاءت نتيجه للاعداد
المتزايده للزوار والمعتمرين الذين كما
سبقنا وصلت اعدادهم تقريبا الى 18 مليون
زائر ومعتمر وتوقعات بان تزيد هذه الاعداد
بكل تاكيد خلال العشر الاواخر بالنسبه
ايضا للتوسعه السعوديه الثالثه اعلنت
الرئاسه عن استكمال اعمال تهيئتها منذ
بدايه شهر رمضان المبارك التوسعه تحوي
خمسه ادوار وسطح يفتح لاول مره في شهر
رمضان المبارك التوس السعوديه الثالثه
تتسع لحوالي مليون و200 الف مصلي في اليوم
الواحد ايضا التوسعه اعلنت التوسعه تشمل
ايضا عدد من الخدمات المزايده متزايده حول
الخدمات المقدمه ايضا للزوار والمعتمرين
ميسون راح نتحدث اليوم ايضا عن توفير
ابواب مخصصه لدخول المعتمرين هي سته ابواب
باب الملك عبد العزيز وباب الملك فهد باب
السلام باب العمره باب الزبير وباب الفتح
وهناك ايضا سته ابواب مخصصه للدخول الى
مصليات المسجد الحرام باب 87.88 و 89 99
و91.74 و 79 هذه الابواب هي الابواب
المخصصه ايضا للدخول لساحات الصلاه كل هذه
الخدمات واكثر نتحدث ايضا عن اليوم خدمات
التفويج واداره الحشود في المسجد الحرام
هناك خطه تشغيليه خاصه بالعشر الاواخر
لتفويج وتنظيم هذه الاعداد المليونيه في
دخولهم وخروجهم الى ساحات المسجد الحرام
من بدايه وصولهم الى محطات النقل واصاله
من المسجد الحرام وايضا ادخالهم واخراجهم
عبر مساحات تردديه يعمل عنها يعمل عليها
رجال الامن وايضا الوكالات المتخصصه في
اداره وتفويج هذه الحشود صوره اخرى مجددا
لهذه الاعداد المليونيه في دخولهم لساحات
المسجد الحرام ودخولهم ايضا من هذه
الابواب الى صحن المطاف وهذه الاعداد
المليونيه الان كما نشاهدها والكثير منها
واكثر اشكرك اسامه على كل هذه التوضيحات
وعلى كل هذه التفاصيل كنت معي من مكه
المكرمه مراسل العربيه اسامه القاسم
[موسيقى]
اعلن نتنياهو بقاء يو اف جلاند في منصبه
كوزير للدفاع وصرح في لقاء تلفزيوني
انجلان سيبقى لحمايه المواطنين
الاسرائيليين مؤكدا انه يعمل
على مدار الساعه
وهذه صور مباشره مشاهدينا من تل ابيب
لمظاهرات ضد قرارات رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو هذه التظاهرات
المستمره منذ اسابيع رفضا للقرارات الذي
التي يود ان يتخذها رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو
وحكومته
اعلان الرئيس الامريكيه جو بايدن نيته
للترشح لعهده ثانيه لم يدفن الجدل الذي
رافق تاخره في اعلان القرار ذاكره تصنع
الجدل وكلمات متلعثمه تتناسق مع خطوات
ثقيله حاله بايدن الصحيه اهم منافس له في
الانتخابات
الخوف ام المرض النسيان ام زلات اللسان
الصحه او التقدم في السن
هل فعلا تلك اسباب دفعت الى تاخر ترشح
بايدن بين بايدن وترامب هكذا ظلت الانظار
مؤخرا تاره تتجه نحو محاكمه ترامب وتاره
نحو جو بايدن منافسه الغائب الحاضر عن
الانتخابات الامريكيه على الاقل حتى
اللحظه
جديد بايدن اعلان خطف فيه الاضواء من
محاكمه ترامب حين قال في مقابله مع برنامج
تودي على شبكه ام بي سي انه يخطط لترشيح
نفسه لكنه ليس مستعدا للاعلان عن ذلك
رسميا
الرئيس الحالي بايدن صاحب الثمانين عاما
يواجه تحديات كثيره قد تكون هي التي منعت
اعلانه الترشح اولها تقدمه في السن فلو
ترشح فعليا انتخابات 2024
فسيكون اكبر مرشح على الاطلاق في تاريخ
الانتخابات ولو فاز سيحافظ بلا شك على
منصب الرئيس الاكبر سنا في تاريخ امريكا
سبب اخر اثار الجدل هل فعلا صحه بايدن
تسمح له بالاستمرار في قياده امريكا
فمؤخرا اعلن رسميا عن ازاله ورم سرطاني
منه وقبل ذلك ثارت تساؤلات كثيره حول
زلاته في الخطابات ونسيانه حتى اسم نائبته
وبالعوده الى ترامب يبقى دوما صراع
الرئاسه مختلفه فالرئيس السابق لم يتوانى
لحظه في استغلال محاكمته لجمع تبرعات
لحملته
وتوظيفها في انتخابات مقبله تكون فيها
الكفه راجحه لصالحه بعض المراقبين قالوا
ان رهبه ترامب واستغلاله كل شيء لخدمه
ترشحه قد يكونان واحدا من الاسباب التي
وترت حياه بايدن واخرت اعلانه الترشح
في ختام اخبار الساعه اذكر بالعناوين
بايدن يعلن نيته الترشح لرئاسيات 2024
لكنه يؤجل الاعلان الرسمي حتى استعداد
حملته
[موسيقى]
السفير السعودي في اليمن يؤكد ان زيارته
الى صنعاء هدفها تثبيت الهدنه والوصول الى
حل سياسي دائم
في جديد الوثائق المسربه خلل في تشغيل
انظمه القنابل الذكيه الامريكيه يجعلها
صيدا سهلا لدفاعات روسيا
والصين تقود بريكس للتوسع في الشرق الاوسط
ووضع حد لهيمنه الدولار عبر التبادل
التجاري بالعملات المحليه
اشكر لكم طيب المتابعه اترككم في امان
الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات